well I remember I do when I was in my
early teens I was really I started
really getting into video games I mean
and the idea of I mean I just play video
games
remember when Sega first came out it was
into this video game it became my new
toy and I mean when video games went
three-dimensional on us
and so as I started you know so physics
for me is no different than being then
it's a form of entertainment for me it's
fun for me it's like playing this video
game and a lot of ways the reason why I
like doing physics the kind of physics I
do is that there's a lot of
visualization going on or actually
experimenting with different ways of
visualizing things and so it becomes
this interesting video game or if you
like translate and I do a lot of
translation between them these images
and equations so it's sort of like you
learn two different languages and the
fun is in translating from one to the
other or looking at something that's
completely understood already and
figuring out a completely different way
of seeing the same thing so physics for
me has always become this is like an
extension of this group a video game a
video game of the mind
therefore I you know even when I
I remember when I lived in London I used
to go to this really interesting school
reggae club and I should take my physics
papers and a pad and go to this reggae
club four o'clock in the morning
sometimes with a colleague and we would
have a pint and we'll be doing physics
in every club and every now and then
like you know some some club or some
dancer would come bias and it would look
at what we're doing and it would be a
source of entertaining for them too
so so I don't I don't mean to to give
this what's the word to misrepresent or
I don't mean to what's we romanticize
yeah but for the most part it has been
this type of this
this form of entertainment I think a
really good book is a book that dear
colleague and friend wrote called three
roads to quantum gravity and it says
actually a small book and it's written
and sort of like you know conversational
tone by Lee Smolin
um it's called three rules of quantum
gravity another book that I would read I
mean of course the elegant universe is a
great book
and no more most people know about I
recommend that too I recommend a book
that will be coming out soon that I will
be a part of it's edited by max Brockman
and it's called new questions coming out
real soon and is a collection of essays
from all different branches of science
which addresses the fundamental issues
in science you know that what are the
big questions what are the new questions
so that book will be coming out real
soon
in many different languages and I think
that book you know will get us you know
gets us up to date and will actually a
good part i book will correlate a lot of
the sciences for each with each other's